[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité des caméras pour
surveiller les forêts la rédaction de
TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest nous
dévoilera dans ce journal les nouveaux
moyens techniques qui seront déployés
dès cet été pour protéger les forêts
girondines l'objectif c'est d'éviter le
scénario catastrophe de l'été dernier
[Musique]
comment mieux lutter contre les feux de
forêt après un été 2022 dévastateur et
des dizaines de milliers d'hectares
partisans fumée les autorités se
préparent pour la période estivale en
Gironde des caméras vont être installés
pour la première fois pour permettre des
interventions plus rapides des pompiers
des moyens techniques qui s'ajoutent à
de nouveaux équipements au sol et dans
les airs les précisions divan branchies
pour TV 7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
c'est l'une des principales techniques
de lutte l'attaque du sinistre par
jalonnement pour empêcher le feu de
s'étendre un type d'intervention mené à
de nombreuses reprises l'été dernier
lors des incendies qui ont ravagé près
de 30 000 hectares en Gironde alors pour
minimiser les risques en 2023 la
priorité est de prévenir et de détecter
rapidement les éventuelles départs de
feu nous développons cette fois-ci c'est
un première partie de programme en 2023
l'assistante 2024 des caméras de vidéos
protection de la forêt à la star de ce
que l'on peut observer dans le
département voisin des Landes lui caméra
développé cette année 14 autres l'année
prochaine à partir du mois d'août 8
châteaux d'eau situés entre le Médoc et
les Landes de Gascogne seront équipés de
ces caméras un dispositif qui s'ajoute
aux annonces il y a trois semaines du
ministre de l'Intérieur Géral de
Darmanin un avion dash 4 avions Air
tractor et un hélicoptère bombardier
d'eau seront ainsi basés cet été en
Gironde avec deux canadairs
prépositionnés en cas de risque les 36
millions d'euros supplémentaires de
l'État permettront aux sapeurs-pompiers
du Sud-Ouest d'acheter des camions et de
renforcer l'effectif en cas de risque
modérés c'est effectivement y avoir une
présence dans le massif de la DFCI de la
part des forces de l'or notamment les
gendarmes mais les policiers mais
également les sapeurs-pompiers dans le
cadre de dispositif qu'on va qu'on va
mettre sur le terrain en fonction du
niveau de risque c'est également une
action de communication pour à travers
la météo des feux pour gérer informer et
sensibiliser la population qu'il faut
faire attention à notre massif un massif
sous haute surveillance cet été que le
préfet pourrait interdire d'accès si le
risque est jugé trop important
voilà et pour lutter contre les
incendies les pompiers peuvent aussi
compter sur la solidarité du monde
viticole dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
d'anciennes cuve à vin servent désormais
de lieu de stockage pour l'eau des
réserves précieuses en cas de feu et qui
évitent d'utiliser l'eau potable les
détails avec ce sujet d'Alizée Marty
pour bien Occitanie
si tu es en plein cœur des fenouillettes
le barrage de caramani alimente
différents canaux d'irrigations comme
celui-ci depuis plusieurs années cette
borne à 110 a été installée par le chef
du centre de secours des stagiaires pour
qu'il puisse s'alimenter facilement en
eau aujourd'hui les pompiers viennent
extraire la ressource tout droit sortie
de cette station de pompage afin de
remplir ses cuves viticoles
de 50000 litres chacune remplie d'eau
donc il nous serviront en cas de feux
d'espace naturel avoir une réserve d'eau
supplémentaire sur le secteur une
vingtaine de culs vont été mises à
disposition par les caves coopératives
du coin afin que le 106 ne manque pas
d'eau pour cette saison estivale qui
s'annonce rude pour les 35 pompiers
volontaires de ce secteur des
Fenouillèdes donc les châteaux d'eau
sont calculés pour le nombre d'habitants
d'éviter de taper sur des châteaux d'eau
et
pénaliser les habitants donc on garde on
garde en stock d'insécure de l'eau
supplémentaires la mobilisation continue
sur le Pyrénées-Orientales une quinzaine
d'autres cafés vont mettre à disposition
leur cuve en plus d'être pompier
volontaires depuis 46 ans Michel et
vigneron Lui qui connaît bien la vigne
rappelle aussi le rôle important de ces
plantations qui dessinent le paysage
catalan ça peut canaliser le feu nous
servir à nous pour essayer de réduire
les flancs et mettre notre personnel en
sécurité surtout lors de l'incendie
Ie de jouer son rôle de coupe-feu mais
jusqu'à quand et après les dégâts des
flammes la vie reprend heureusement ses
droits en forêt exemple dans la Sarthe
ou un terrain de 32 hectares vient
d'être entièrement reboisé
50000 pouces ont été plantés un travail
conséquent et qui s'inscrit bien sûr
dans le temps un reportage de Laurent
Girard pour elle MTV
à Ruaudin là où la forêt a brûlé en
juillet 2022 c'est une pousse parmi des
milliers qui vont être replantés cette
semaine sur une parcelle privée un
chantier d'envergure et un travail à la
chaîne on les plantes avec une distance
demandée là c'est un mètre 50 entre
chaque plan et on continue comme ça
jusqu'à 17h mais on peut monter à 1000
100 1200 tout dépendre de notre forme
planter à la pelle ou plus rapide à la
canne s'épouce de pain maritime sont
adaptés au sol sableux de Ruaudin mais
on met aussi d'autres essences et
notamment du feuillus par îlot par et
par ligne pour la diversité de la
parcelle ça participe aussi à ce qui est
mis en place aussi aujourd'hui pour
essayer d'éviter que les mêmes choses se
reproduisent c'est-à-dire notamment les
fûts qui m'ont brûler moins vite que les
résineux donc ça va permettre de
temporiser un petit peu par endroits le
feu le temps que les secours
interviennent un chantier débuté à
l'automne dernier il a d'abord fallu
déboiser et valoriser les souches qui
pouvaient l'être mais pour présenter une
parcelle aussi vaste de 32 hectares il a
aussi fallu faire appel à la générosité
d'entreprises partenaires pour récolter
un budget de 250 000 euros sans fonds
publics l'entreprise et coterie apporte
cette aide technique et financière aux
propriétaires privés pour reboiser
massivement
une entreprise donc qui est leader
européen des solutions fondées sur la
nature et donc qui va permettre aux
entreprises et aux particuliers de
s'engager pour la restauration des
écosystèmes pour la préservation de la
biodiversité là on est sur la plantation
qui dure à peu près une semaine pour la
moitié de la parcelle et une nouvelle
semaine donc l'année prochaine pour
l'autre moitié de la parcelle et puis
ensuite on a évidemment tout le suivi
qui va se faire par étape chaque année
en attendant que ces pousses deviennent
grandes et ramènent toute la BI
odivers avant sur cette parcelle
Caron était invité jeudi matin de
l'émission Face au territoire sur TV5
Monde le député la France insoumise a
été questionnée notamment sur son
engagement pour la cause animale écoutez
ce qu'il a dit les sondages nudistes
contre 8 et 9 Français sur 10 souhaitent
la fin de la corrida et néanmoins on a
vu que ma proposition de loi était
bloquée à l'Assemblée ce blocage a été
permis par l'intersection de nos
institutions je vais peut-être pas
revenir dans l'état des choses mais bref
c'était présenté en cas d'une niche
parlementaire qui est limitée en temps
et donc il y avait tellement d'amour
farfelus
techniques là je suis en train de passer
par la commission des lois pour leur
demander de remettre le sujet dans
l'hémicycle mais simplement il faut que
pour ça que je puisse convaincre
d'autres groupes que la France insoumise
vous constatez que lorsqu'une
municipalité organise une feria aurait
été il y a à peu près 5% seulement des
spectateurs si les gens qui est un
million de personnes qui viennent il y
en a que 5 % qui vont se déplacer à une
coda et on pourrait même imaginer la
chose faire c'est à dire que si elle
avait plus de corrida il y a peut-être
plus de gens qui iraient au feria face
au territoire avec Aymeric Caron est à
voir ou à revoir sur le site internet de
TV5 Monde et sur celui des partenaires
de l'émission Ouest-France Nice-Matin
france-anti 20 minutes la montagne
Centre France et le magazine Le Point
allez passons à un sujet qui doit
forcément préoccuper aymeric Caron avec
la problématique Coran sûrement
remarquer les propriétaires d'animaux de
compagnie la hausse des coûts de
l'alimentation animale + 20 % en
quelques mois conséquence les
propriétaires sont désormais plus
attentifs à l'heure d'acheter des
croquettes ou du pâté pour leur
compagnon à petites pattes la preuve
avec ce sujet des Norah le nôtre pour
Tébéo la chaîne du groupe Le Télégramme
en Bretagne
c'est l'heure de manger pour gâteau mais
depuis quelques mois s'appropriétaire
Marie-Catherine fait attention aux
quantités le prix des croquettes a
augmenté et la du s’adapter alors pour
leur santé non j'ai pas voulu
effectivement je préfère privilégier les
croquettes de bonne qualité maintenant
j'ai c'est quand même un petit peu de
les rationner c'est vrai que le côté à
volonté un petit peu moins par rapport
au prix depuis fin 2022 l'alimentation
animale fait face à une hausse des prix
d'environ 20%. une augmentation qui
impacte les propriétaires d'animaux mais
aussi les refuges animaliers
Marie-Catherine est la secrétaire de
l'association Teacha 29 une association
de sauvetage de chats qui ne vit que de
dons et elle remarque un changement de
comportement des donateurs mois décembre
on a fait une collecte pour pouvoir
nourrir les chats que l'on avait en
accueil et la collecte a été bien moins
généreuse que ce qu'on avait l'habitude
de recevoir dans les magasins
d'alimentation animale des solutions ont
été mises en place pour tenter de
pallier à l'inflation mais les vendeurs
notent tout de même un changement
d'habitude consommateurs on voit un
changement de consommation donc en fait
soit nos clients restent fidèles à leur
marque de croquettes et repousser des
achats qui sont non essentiels par
exemple sur du jouet sur des produits
high-tech soit ils vont privilégier des
moments où il y a des promotions les
Français dépensent en moyenne 59 euros
par mois pour nourrir leur animal de
compagnie associée aux soins d'entretien
ce budget monta 943 euros par an soit
125 euros de plus qu'en 2020
voilà et dans ce contexte de hausse des
prix les chiffres de l'emploi demeur
positifs moins de chômeurs et des offres
qui peinent à trouver preneur à l'instar
des métiers de la restauration se des
travaux publics sont également à la
recherche de candidats pour répondre à
la demande du marché exemple à Limoges
ou le centre de formation et d'insertion
au métier du BTP propose plusieurs voix
professionnelles vers l'emploi images et
propos recueillies par Alain Druot pour
cette à Limoges
spécifiquement sur quatre grandes
familles des métiers ou qui sont les
plus demandeurs d'emploi à l'heure
actuelle le métier de canalisateur le
métier de maçon VRD consulvaire de route
le métier de conducteur d'engins de
chantier et le métier de monteur de
réseau électrique sinon vous avez 11
métiers 22 spécialités donc le champ de
d'activité est très large
sans transition direction
Aix-en-Provence dans ce journal ou un
square au nom du journal La Marseillaise
vient d'être inaugurée à quelque part
seulement de l'endroit où est né le
journal en 1943 grâce à l'action de
militants communistes une inauguration
pour se souvenir de la bravoure et du
courage de ces résistances et l'occasion
pour nous de souhaiter également un
joyeux anniversaire à nos partenaires de
la Marseillaise des images de
Marie-Laure Thomas et de Léa Cornu tout
à fait autre chose leur nombre augmente
chaque année à l'heure des départs en
vacances les cambriolages peuvent être
souvent évités grâce au respect de
quelques règles élémentaires des règles
vous le voyez sur ces images qui est
venu rappeler le temps d'une matinée
près de Toulouse l'ancien capitaine du
XV de France Fabien Pelous l'ex rugbyman
et son maître 98 ont prêté main forte
aux gendarmes lors d'une opération de
sensibilisation sur un marché écoutez-le
au micro de Clément cassis pour nos
partenaires de la Dépêche du Midi
moi j'aime bien que mon image cerve
aussi à autre chose qu'à moi-même le
fait de pouvoir par mon image diffusé au
plus grand nombre je crois que c'est
mais c'est en tout cas le sens de mon
engagement sur cette opération peu
vraiment arriver à n'importe qui donc
juste par les quelques petites postures
que l'on peut que l'on peut adopter un
peu on peut faire finalement de grande
différence allez on poursuit ce journal
avec ces images impressionnantes de
télégronome et de l'installation de la
plus grande tyrolienne à pylône du monde
dans la station de Chamrousse longue de
plus de 2 km celle-ci permettra
d'effectuer une descente avec des
pointes à 80 km/h ouverture au public
prévu le 17 juin prochain un moyen pour
la station de diversifier ses activités
précisions recueillies par Théo Laroche
pour Télé Grenoble écouter les gens ont
changé l'attitude face à la montagne
maintenant on est plus sur des dévoreurs
de domaine et des voies de journée on
est sur des gens qui font 3 heures de
ski dans la journée ensuite cherche une
activité
on va dire annexe à réaliser ça restera
évidemment un produit exceptionnel je
pense un produit qu'on fait l'hiver
qu'on fait l'été qu'on offre pour un
anniversaire
voilà pour les amateurs de sensations
fortes notaient qu'il vous faudra
débourser 35 euros pour profiter de
cette descente 60 mètres au-dessus du
sol
à quelques kilomètres de là sur le lac
d'Annecy c'est un drôle d'engin qui est
entré en action en ce mois de mai comme
chaque année depuis presque 20 ans
désormais une machine amphibie est
chargée de gratter les fonds du lac
objectif lutter contre la prolifération
de la puce du canard et d'autres espèces
indésirables précision de Sébastien
Germain pour la rédaction de 8 Mont
Blanc
il régnait comme un petit air d'été ce
mercredi sur les bords du lac d'Annecy
sous un soleil de plomb ils étaient
nombreux à être venus profiter de ses
températures presque estivales au bord
du lac à la plage d'Albigny à quelques
kilomètres de là le panorama est bien
différent au marquisat si les bateaux
sont de sortie ici la baignade est
interdite et tout l'après-midi un drôle
d'engins va enchaîner les allers-retours
le long de la rive avec un objectif bien
précis faire la chasse à la puce du
canard le but de la machine c'est de
gratter le fond les substrats pour faire
sortir le parasite qui se trouve dans un
petit escargot qui est au fond de l'eau
avec Claire son gratte le fond
mécaniquement pour casser l'escargot
pour qu'il sorte avant la baignade
organisé chaque année avant l'été depuis
2005 par le sida le syndicat
intercommunal du lac d'Annecy cette
campagne visa avant tout à limiter la
prolifération de la puce du canard et ce
depuis sa base dans la fiente du canard
vous avez les parasites l'éliminer ce
qui sont des petits escargots au fond du
lac donc mange cette fiente et ensuite
libère une puce et un seul limitée on
peut libérer jusqu'à plus de 2000 puces
donc la puce ensuite recherche un corps
à son chou et alors où elle retrouve le
canard où elle retrouve le où elle
trouve le baigneur cette période
d'avantaison estivale est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler les bons gestes à
adopter face à la menace de la moule
kuaga qui guette le lac d'Annecy à
savoir bien laver les embarcations ou
encore vidanger les réservoirs
doublé de vigilance parce qu'on sait que
le lac Léman est infesté on sait que le
lac du Bourget est infesté et que ça a
des impacts extrêmement importants sur
la distribution de l'eau potable à
Annecy 70% de l'eau potable et distribué
et vient du lac donc c'est important de
préserver nos canalisations d'eau
potable sinon ça coûterait extrêmement
cher cette opération anti-espèce
aquatique indésirable va durer jusqu'au
22 mai 2023 sur 6 plages tout autour du
lac entre Annecy et Sevrier
voilà sur l'eau restons-y dans ce
journal avec cette bonne idée d'évasion
avec le retour des beaux jours que
diriez-vous d'une escapade à bord d'un
bateau sans permis et oui c'est possible
notamment en Bretagne vous allez le voir
quelques conseils techniques avant le
départ suffisent et les marins d'eau
douce peuvent s'embarquer pour un voyage
un sujet de la rédaction de TVR regarde
nous allons rentrer tranquillement dans
l'écluse on s'amarre avant l'écluse ou
naviguer sur un fleuve pour ce couple
Brestois c'est une première
le klaxon
et le stop du coup il est que en bas et
qu'en bas durant 3 jours Anne-Isabelle
et Sylvain vont remonter la Vilaine et
l'affe de Guy primessac jusqu'à La
Gacilly c'était mon anniversaire cette
semaine
et puis on avait envie de changer un
petit peu
du camion parce qu'on a un transporteur
donc c'est une autre façon de de voyager
15 heures de bateau rythmé par le
passage des écluses faut bien savoir
comment s'y prendre
où elle se trouve quel ponton on peut
s'arrêter lesquels on peut pas s'arrêter
mais avant de prendre le fleuve il faut
avoir le bateau en main la rivière est
totalement différente de la mer les
codes de navigation sont différentes la
façon de naviguer était tellement
différente il y a pas de courant le vent
tout ça joue beaucoup dans la navigation
en rivière pour les entrées des écluses
qui sont beaucoup plus étroites un
bateau de moins de 15 mètres qu'ils ont
loué au port de Guipry Messac cette
entreprise est spécialisée dans les
bateaux fluvio c'est l'une des seules en
Ille-et-Vilaine a proposé ce type de
séjour sur l'un de ses 23 bâtiments la
quasi-totalité est louée durant les
vacances de Pâques ce jour ils seront
trois familles à récupérer leurs clés
tous à la recherche d'un peu de
tranquillité on va chercher les coins de
nature des petites visites par exemple
comme lagacy leur Redon ou La
Roche-Bernard qui sont des villes qui
attirent énormément nos clients
notre région compte 570 km de canaux
répartis sur trois sections navigables
l'occasion de faire une pause au fil de
l'eau
voilà et si l'art prenait possession du
mitard à Doullens dans la Somme un
collectif de street artistes à investi
le temps d'une exposition éphémère
l'historique citadelle de la ville sur
les murs et dans les cellules des
peintures et des collages rendent
hommages aux femmes parfois mineurs qui
ont été privées de liberté dans ses
anciens bâtiments militaires un travail
à découvrir jusqu'en septembre prochain
et dont Jérémie Houbron vous dévoile
quelques images pour ce sujet de oui au
TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du
Courrier Picard
des visages presque fantomatiques comme
des ombres venus d'un lointain passé
[Musique]
une inspiration artistique née d'un
passé de souffrance quant à la fin du
19e siècle la citadelle devient une
école de préservation pour jeunes filles
mineures parfois mère ou enceinte les
plus rétives se voyaient enfermés ici on
fait mention d'usage de camisole donc
des jeunes filles étaient camisolées
beaucoup de mentions de suicide
également donc on est vraiment dans
quelque chose d'extrêmement violent si
les archives manuscrites évoquent la
souffrance de ces jeunes femmes les
cellules elles-mêmes portent encore les
stigmates du passé à l'image des
dizaines d'inscriptions qui recouvrent
ces murs des fragments de vie qu'il faut
savoir observer on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
des dizaines d'inscriptions reste à
faire dans cette turne
230 jours vive la quille sous les
peintures collage des sculptures du
collectif curb les vies de ces femmes
prisonnières sont remises en lumière
l'exposition transgression restera
accessible aux visiteurs au moins
jusqu'en septembre
voilà de la culture encore en milieu
carcéral avec cette fois-ci un concert
et un atelier musical dont on peut
profiter une cinquantaine de détenus
d'un centre pénitentiaire martiniquais
invité pour l'occasion l'artiste
jamaïcain Fantan moja un moment de
détente mais aussi de réflexion pour ces
prisonniers précisions recueillies par
Aude Sioul tidas pourvient à TV
Martinique
un moment de pur bonheur et d'amusement
[Musique]
une cinquantaine de détenus ont pu
décompresser avec leur artiste préféré
et c'est lyrix aux bonnes vibrations
[Musique]
on va dire que c'est pas donné à toutes
les prisons pour la première fois au
centre pénitentiaire de Ducos des
détenus de différents secteurs se sont
rassemblés des prévenus à ceux ayant de
lourdes peines ils étaient accompagnés
ce sont des plus léopènes mais ils ont
quand même le doigt de fêter ils ont
fait comme le doigt de s'amuser et c'est
un moment intéressant pour eux ce
rassemblement festif n'était que de
courte durée et a débuté par un groupe
de parole pour motiver les détenus et
lutter contre la récidive il faut savoir
que c'est pas un concert c'est un
atelier qui fait partie d'un programme
éducatif
destiné à des tenues
leur dette à la société mais qui ont
besoin aussi comme tout à chacun de
prendre des temps de réflexion sur des
questions peut-être qui se posent seuls
au fond de leur cellules l'artiste
fontaine moja a aussi encouragé les
détenus afin de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient une deuxième chance
[Musique]
l'artiste a déjà promis son retour sur
la scène carcérale martiniquaise
convaincue que cela changera les esprits
allez on referme ce journal à la
découverte d'un métier rare bronzier
d'art une profession que pratique depuis
l'âge de 17 ans Jean-Maurice Célérier
dans l'Aube dans son atelier ce
passionné restaure des portails des
statues et des mobiliers venus du monde
entier et parmi ses clients les plus
fidèles le gouvernement américain rien
que ça fait appel souvent à lui un sujet
de la rédaction de Canal 32 sur place
les clients ne se bronzier d'art le
qualifie de sauveur du patrimoine c'est
par le gouvernement américain donc là il
a fallu que je refasse le plâtre d'après
une photo ce meilleur ouvrier de France
de compte plus les restaurations
réalisées pour le gouvernement américain
dans son atelier de Vulaines la dernière
a nécessité 4 mois d'efforts alors
supportage j'ai refait
toute cannisme
permettait
d'y a tellement de manutention sur ce
type de produit qui dépasse la tonne que
chaque manipulation est très longue les
patines sont en cours de finition hormis
les aspects mécaniques sa mission
consiste parfois à recréer des pièces on
pourrait bien évidemment refaire le
médaillon central à l'identique si 90%
de ces commandes sont voies à l'export
une exception au Boisse est un cours de
restauration pour la ville de Troyes
intitulé lydiele ou la pêche cette
sculpture orne la place Foch à 3
Jean-Maurice et la créa à partir de
moulage de l'oeuvre originale de Joseph
Marius aujourd'hui cette copie a subi
les affres du temps Jean-Maurice
céleriet a commencé son parcours
d'apprentissage à l'âge de 17 ans au
sein de plusieurs écoles dont boule
hormis les commandes publiques il crée
également des pièces uniques comme ses
pieds de tabourets pour des particuliers
exigeants discrets et parfois fortunés
là nous avons l'objet qui a été
entièrement ciselé c'est pour ça qu'on
voit le bronze naturelle qui ont été
ciselés donc avec les petits ciselés des
petits outils de comme ceci et en
finition on va le il voit doré donc
voilà l'objet fini dorer avant d'être
monté le métier de bronzier d'art est un
peu répandu grâce à son savoir-faire les
commandes se succèdent constamment
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi ce grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une prochaine édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]